hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm a property investor and you know
what if you want to really win at
property
you've got to be prepared to go there
where other people won't go there so in
the uk
if you go through somewhere like the
peak district which is where i am right
now there's so many little buildings
outlets
sheds barns that are so tiny they're so
grotty
surely you can do nothing with them like
this thing over here like what is that
what is that there's no windows it's
probably disgusting inside
how could we possibly make money out of
this okay brace yourself
oh my goodness
i mean this is absolutely disgusting
it doesn't look fit for horses let alone
people
however in this video i'm going to show
you how my parents their whole strategy
is they take little barns like this and
they
buy them they restore them make them
look fabulous
and then refinance and pull their money
out and then
rent them out as serviced accommodation
little holiday let's it's a great little
strategy
and i'm going to take you through a to z
exactly how it works
okay so here we are in the middle of
fields
this is like one of those little barn
things that you see in fact there's
another one
right there there's absolutely loads
like this so let's take a look around
and see what's happening
[Music]
hello hello all right
so this is tim and sue
my parents and this is your barn
it's nice it's nicer than the one we've
just been at
but it's still i can't quite
imagine it being luxurious don't
visualize it
no no it will be so what's the crap then
talk to me about your strategy and how
you find these types of little barns
we drive around the area and find barns
a lot of them i'm just imagining right
now that i'm staying here for the night
so talk to me about the figures then of
this property you found this property
on an auction right and he was on an
estate agent yeah
what happened so it was on with an
estate agent but it was to auction
yeah and we always go to the auction and
then it goes for sky-high prices
much higher than the guide price so we
decided
to put an offer in pre-auction so the
guide price was 70 to 100
and we thought we'll go for a hundred
but they were like going blue
we were like we want to offer on this
property
no we don't want to take offers you've
got to go to the auction yeah
but but but we want to put an offer on
foot no if they just said yes if they'd
gone all right you cover 100
you've literally just bought it for 100
would have been really happy but they
didn't even
yeah because we could have said a
million pounds couldn't wait they just
weren't listening no they weren't
listening okay so what happened when
you're into auction tim
went to auction now i've been to a lot
of property auctions
but this was different this was like a
car auction very fast bidding and we're
the fourth one lot on
and they're bidding and i couldn't tell
what they go up in price was it five
thousand six that
anyway it got to seventy eight thousand
pounds and he's about badge put the
hammer down
and i bid i thought oh my bidding 79 or
80. so he took 80.
and it took 80. he said going going gone
had it for 80 000. got it for 80 000.
nice all right well let's have a look
around
i was shocked when i first saw this at
how tiny it is and you did warn me that
it's small
this is very very small there is an
upstairs area
so what's this gonna be i mean i'm
trying to visualize it tim what's your
view
there's gonna be a kitchen which is
gonna run straight down here yeah
and it'll be high class kitchen yeah
solid wood throughout
and then this area becomes a living area
yeah
so we have a little table here sofa here
yep
log burner over here people will stay
here will be people who want to walk
yeah and as we've been working on this
property we've seen people walking
outside
down the fields then there there are
plenty of walks around here yeah and
people come just just to be and
experience this area
it doesn't have to be large too yeah and
this will be this is
typical for couples and also when you
live somewhere
you know your garage is probably this
size and it gets full of junk but when
you're on holiday
you've got a bag and that's it
everything's in the thing that i think
is so interesting with this strategy and
i will be your first guest
as soon as it's ready august 10 is the
fact that you've combined by
refurbished refinance with service
accommodation
so i mean you're doing the work yourself
yeah you bought it for
80 grand how much are you spending on it
what's the it looks like you've already
started a bit
like what have you done so far what
you're doing so far some things you
can't see
if you go over here you'll see it's
black
behind there yeah that is a black
membrane and the whole is
these three walls of that that's because
there's
damp coming through here and we've had
to
monitor that what was this useful before
is this for animals or
girls cows yeah farmer tells me it's
like cows
so this went from a cow barn
to a cow shed to what will be a
luxury holiday home yeah which is
incredible okay what else have you done
here this is a plywood ceiling
not normal you'll see upstairs plywood
floor
you can see in here head height is quite
an issue
um when we bought this barn they had
done work on it already
hadn't complied with building legs at
all and you can see over there
this is a 4.5 meter span with six inch
joists
the floor bounced so i had to
have this stress built
so you've got plywood in here screws in
it's all been structural surveyor has
come up with this idea
now that floor is firm it doesn't bounce
at all
extra costs i didn't expect we've taken
out the stairs which you can see outside
a bit of stairs talk to me about how the
stairs work
you came into this door and the stairs
went very steep up there
you almost went to a climbing stairs you
almost climbed them because they were so
steep
they again didn't comply with building
rigs so they had to go
yeah um we reconfigured it
so when you go upstairs you've got head
height when you get upstairs
everything's about head heart in this
house so and and tim is one of the very
strange few people that i know
that go to planning meetings with
no agenda other than just to learn about
planning is that is that right
mom talk about that what he does because
i find it very peculiar
well when people want to apply for
planning permission
um they go and sit at this committee and
thing but it's
open for public so anybody can go so tim
turns up every month at the meetings
with no
barn just to hear what other people do
just to see
and be creative and know how to think
like it's like an education
yeah so what happens is that he comes
home and he goes oh
you've got to have so many inches and
it's all like
lodged in here so when we now go and
look at barnes
he got more of an idea yeah whether it
will get passed or not you know what's
so interesting about that is planning
permission it does vary doesn't it from
from
property to property and area to area
and the fact what what you've done
you've moved into an area
got to know got a very niche strategy
got to know all the rules attend the
planning meetings
it's really really strict here because
you know
um permitted development it's not
allowed anywhere here
really in the whole of the peak district
nothing so you can't go resi to office
to resi
you can't do anything like that
basically you know
listed buildings basically this isn't
listed
but they treat it like it is yeah so
it's got the same kind of
everything here it's got the same kind
of rules but the thing is
to most people that would be a nightmare
yeah but to tim
mr planner yeah that knows the rules
understands it it's actually good
because it creates a high barrier to
entry for other people which means that
everyone else will be scared off
oh these little bars i don't know how
the planning works i don't know who
deals with the planning whereas because
you've got in on the area
got knowledge really high to you it's oh
you just do this this and this
and then your competition runs away tim
how much money is it going to cost you
with planning what you've had or
everything all included
how much money is it going to cost you
to get this at the level where you want
it
round figures 40 forty thousand so you
bought it for eighty yeah
you're gonna be spending forty thousand
on it a lot of the work you do yourself
yep
and that means total one twenty
what's the end value expected today and
be conservative because i'm gonna come
back when we know
and you'd rather it be you'd rather be
conservative 190
conservative 190
i mean honestly if this little thing
could be 190
i think that is that'll be incredible
let's go upstairs okay
so this is this is like the tiniest
little upstairs
the tiniest little says ever um what's
happening here then tim
this with bedroom and where you're
standing will be the bed
okay and presumably this would be
a bathroom okay yeah okay nice
great so you're gonna stay in here
and you've got a nice decent sized
bedroom
bathroom downstairs lounge to be fair
for a week
a little romantic break it's nice
talk to me tim about finance so
type of mortgage you'll get on this
learn to value
how much you have to put down of your
own money we were able to bridge any of
the money
we had money about thirty odd thousand
pounds
we bridged fifty two thousand okay
um so you bought so you bought it for 80
000
you put down about 30 grand about 50
grand you bridged yeah what about the
refurb
refurb i got some money from somewhere
else
i applied to various places i managed to
get two lots of
loans okay is that is that like private
invest investors or no
just normal finance companies like uh
like a loan
yeah that's good and that's the thing
with
properties like this it doesn't matter
where the money comes from it's not like
you're doing a buy to let where they'll
be saying where's where's
your deposit coming from where's doesn't
matter because
that type of finance okay and then when
you refinance it what kind of mortgage
will you get
commercial type finance yeah just to
cover holiday let's see old stairs these
are the old stairs try looking at it
samuel
oh my god heavy isn't it i don't know
i'll put my back out
i can't lift that but
they look like great great stairs i mean
good stairs for a cow shed
but not good stairs for a holiday home
great what you've done so talk to me
tim about how do you even are you gonna
will there be wi-fi here wi-fi will have
to be
uh vodafone we'll have to be mobile we
can't get
wi-fi here can you get 4g you should get
4g on vodafone yeah
okay what about power and
heating interesting there is no
electricity here oh my goodness i'm
beginning to wonder whether i want to be
your first guest
so no wi-fi no heating and no heating
though
no so how are you going to get heating
oh well
next to the the building here
is going to be built a generator house
okay obviously in a styling keeping with
what planning you just
want so from here to there
the roof is going to be a generator
house you'll have a generator and
batteries in there
we haven't finalised on what generator
we're having yet that's still in
in process could there be any issues
with that happening yeah
yeah and is that included in the forty
thousand pound yeah
okay and we're going to have
um rpg gas yeah absolutely
and the the power getting put in them
from the generator is that expensive how
much is that going to cost
it's going to cost per 9 000 pounds to
have the
extension put on and then about 5 000
pounds to generate a
expensive part of the project this is so
without that
this doesn't make any sense he's gonna
cost like 15 grand just to get power
yeah and the whole refurb is
40 grand inside is just 25 grand
wow there's a sewage plant going yet
which is another five grand
okay half the price so that is gonna put
people off isn't it yeah
that's the thing there's no power
there's no wi-fi
people are just gonna write off this
kind of building we did look
into having power not the generator but
actual
overhead power but that was more
expensive wasn't it how much was that
80 to 100 000 pounds oh goodness
my goodness well the farmer asked us if
we could he could put some sheep on here
yeah and i think that's probably the
best option
because it's good to get on with your
neighbours and yeah and if
if the people in the area i mean not
there's many neighbours
here but if people like if you've got
local farmers and stuff that like you
yeah
and supporting what you're doing because
you've let them put sheep in your bit
it's good for you because you're not
going to cut the grass right but then
presumably the farmer it's just nice to
have people that like you
in the area isn't it yeah not making
your life difficult and fighting your
every move and
oh you've got people coming in and
coming out and i'm watching the problem
you just want people to be
for you yeah and for everybody else yeah
it's nice enough you can't do anything
with it anyway exactly so that makes
sense
when i was talking to the farmer the
other day he was telling me a bit about
this
property and he said when the previous
person had it
the pitch of the roof was like that yeah
and he took it down
and he's increased the pitch to get the
extra head height okay
so that's how because because without
that without an upstairs
this would this would be worthless
really wouldn't it it would be literally
only good
i would say for man nor beast maybe
beast but definitely not mad
but that's great perfect
oh my goodness it looks
so different
this refurb is now completely done i'm
staying here
overnight and it's beautiful i mean you
guys have been such a great job
congratulations thank you
because if you remember what this looked
like before i mean i remember thinking
it was just it was it was
an animal farm you know it was terrible
and when i came before you'd already
done
quite a lot of the work yeah and it was
but now it's so homely you've done such
a good job of the kitchen
and you you really decided tim you just
said i want to go the extra mile with
the
quality so talk to me about the kitchen
this is not the album's kitchen is it
no there's nothing how dare you suggest
it tell me where you got the kitchen
from and how much you spent on the
kitchen yes
the wicks kitchen this is all oak oh
look sorry
carcasses sort of workshops
nice and you've gone for the spotlights
yeah
nice floor stone floor yeah i like it
i'm gonna have dinner in a minute but
i'm starving um all right tell me
upstairs
what's been your involvement mom with
the whole reverb wow
on the phone chasing people yeah finding
builders
oh this is great this
i've got to say i don't know how you've
made it
so spacious feeling
this is brilliant i love it i am so
impressed good
right there there's some hidden things
in this go on
the bed was one of the first things that
was done
before i started working the bar and the
bed was the first thing okay the bed has
been i've reconfigured the bed i've
lowered the bed
up to make it lower so i can get the
height in here
so i can take the wall further back
right
the original architect had the walls out
to here that wouldn't have worked
it wouldn't have worked that wouldn't
have worked i really think that's why he
sold it
because he realized halfway through he
couldn't do it oh you think the initial
owner
couldn't do it yeah that's the thing
fixing
problems yeah even think guys even stuff
like this
normally people would have just put
wooden beams down
but you've put glass there which makes
this tiny
barn suddenly feel spacious yeah i also
didn't want to
take away from the view of the beams
that have gone in so you can still do
the beams through the yellow yeah
absolutely fabulous and then the
bathroom is still here right
and then the toilet beams that yes cover
the steel girder that was there before
okay but you've again turned something
bad into something good
and the views are breathtaking aren't
they yep this is a great the thing is as
well
is i mean the way you've used the space
is fabulous where's the uh oh the
toilet's doing
even things like the the toilet holder
yeah on the door
and you've got a nice size shower in
which is what you wanted i'm not gonna
lie when i came out here i remember
thinking
i can't because you've changed it so
much just little tweaks i'm thinking how
are you gonna fit a bird
and even if you do where are you gonna
get the chest of drawers on that you've
just
you've done it great and you've you know
where the first time
tomorrow television tomorrow great
you thought you'd wait for me sir you
know i don't like tv
absolutely fabulous another thing as
well is
because of the lockdown the lockdown's
now lifting
so presumably you'll get bookings on
this quite quickly yeah that's what they
said when they came to take the
photographs he said you need to get on
really fast yeah because it's all
filling up everywhere
how much are you looking at how much are
you hoping to get
rent for this with the holiday you know
the holidays and stuff like what's the
plan financially
i'm saying 500 a week okay 500
i've averaged throughout the year okay
probably
700 peak so after all costs
cleaners maintenance voids
how much profit are you hoping to make
off of this
little tiny x animal house how much are
you hoping to make
i'm saying thousand pounds a month yeah
i'm not going to go to the news pound
but
i think i think you'll get that yeah i
think you'll get that
it's great it's absolutely great and
because it's so unique and in such a
nice spot we think we'll get repeat
people
coming in yeah you will you will yeah i
want to know
step outside why it's still light
ultimately we want to know what the end
value on this is because i think that's
that that's the big thing what the costs
were what's the money
yeah all right talk through the figures
so talk to you about how many months did
this take you in total the works
yes yeah a year took a year
so so it took a lot longer than you
hoped
you did how much did how much were you
hoping the refurb would be and how much
actually was it
when i went to auction i did some quick
calculations
did some quick inquiries and i reckon 30
000 pounds
yeah i but i knew it was a barn i'd
never done a bar before
i was expecting problems when i went for
finance which after i bought the
property to the refurb
my calculations were around about the 50
000 pound market on stage i thought
because because i've met such a saving
on the buy i know
how much do they end up at 63 63. so the
so the time scale was worse
the budget was not in place however
overall it was a success because you're
going to get a really good profit from
it every month
yeah and you bought it for 80. you spent
63
total that's 143 how did you feel about
the revaluation
really happy what was it 200 200
000 that's great but you said to the
value when he came did you have to
did you know we pre-empted it go on
there's nothing like this around
yeah and typically they down value
properties like this because they might
be coming from somewhere like in the
city and they look at the size
right and they don't really know the
value so we decided to get a rick's
valuation on it
yeah so when they came to value it we
told them we'd had a risk valuation and
we were hoping for 200.
so that was a kind of a okay yeah a
little bit of a twist of an arm so it's
not just
hitting hope there's things that you can
do to give yourself the best chances
yeah but the value only came out you
know what valuables are like yeah
these he was nice and he loved the
property he said i could stay here
myself
yeah i know that thought i thought yeah
he's going to like it yeah
yeah get them all side yeah everyone's
everyone's a human being at the end of
the day
yeah so you're gonna what pull your
money out now refinance it
rent it out provide a beautiful holiday
home and then make a nice income from it
yeah and you've got other projects going
on
yeah yes got another one just down the
road is it another barn
no it's listed though
sounds to me guys like we have another
video coming soon
with their next project so if you
enjoyed this video
smash the like button subscribe if you
want to see more videos like this you
can check out a whole playlist
up here right now we're going to go
inside and we're going to enjoy some of
my mom's wonderful wonderful cooking
hey great job tim cracking job
congratulations see you next time